the main point is that observations of  the universe made by people like you  have revealed something incredible which  is that the universe is unbelievably  simple and by simple I mean very  economical in what it takes to describe  it you just need five numbers and so far  there's no evidence for anything more  than those five numbers whereas when we  look at our theories they have become  unbelievably complex cane with a million  assumptions and fixes and starting about  five years ago I basically decided this  has all become you know a bit of a joke  to to be honest but what we should be  doing is being strongly Guided by the  data to constructing much simpler models  of the universe